y
[Música]
ah
japón todavía no se repone del shock que
represento para la sociedad de ese país
y para la clase política el asesinato
del ex primer ministro shinzo abe que
murió al recibir dos disparos durante un
acto de campaña pese a haberse retirado
de su cargo como primer ministro a bs
seguía siendo una figura clave en la
vida pública japonesa seguía siendo tal
vez el político japonés más destacado y
tal vez el más reconocido a nivel
internacional era integrante de una
dinastía de políticos era hijo de un ex
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
shintaro ave y también nieto de un ex
primer ministro de japón no busque y sí
conoció el poder político desde muy
pequeño y era apodado informalmente como
el príncipe veamos algunos datos
relevantes shinzo abe era integrante del
partido liberal democrático ndp en 1993
fue elegido como integrante del
parlamento japonés en 2006 asume el
cargo de primer ministro con sólo 52
años es el primer ministro más joven en
la historia de japón desde la edad de
postguerra en asumir el cargo entre 2012
y 2020 tiene lugar su segundo mandato es
así como se convierte en el primer
ministro que más años ha estado en ese
cargo su estrategia de estímulo
económico para el archipiélago japonés
fue llamada ave no mix y esta estrategia
como toda la vida pues tuvo sus
seguidores y sus detractores logró
dinamizar en cierta forma la economía
japonesa pero luego se ralentizó ya lo
vamos a analizar en unos minutos a nivel
internacional le dio mucha visibilidad a
japón
no en vano ave era tal vez el político
japonés como ya lo decía más reconocido
a nivel mundial con muy buenas
relaciones sobre todo con occidente pero
mantuvo sus altibajos en cuanto a las
relaciones que japón mantiene con korea
con china y con rusia con este último
país mantiene una tensa relación por el
archipiélago de las islas kuriles como
se les conoce desde el lado ruso cuál es
entonces el legado político de shinzo
abe quien asumirá ese vacío que deja él
en la escena política nipona porque pese
a su retiro seguía siendo tan respetado
en la vida pública japonesa porque fue
asesinado que dice en los primeros
indicios del este hoy en el debate de
france 24 shinzo abe el impacto de su
asesinato hemos invitado para hablar
sobre este tema al doctor yo mucho él es
profesor de ciencias políticas de la wan
6 gakuin university que está ubicada en
kobe en japón también saludamos en la
ciudad de honolulu en el archipiélago de
hawai en eeuu a florentino rodado él es
catedrático de la universidad
complutense de madrid y es autor del
libro la sociedad del país vulnerable
japón
les recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de esta conversación dejen todas
sus preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde no se
encuentran como france24 bajo ese
sentido que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
también en youtube pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming y también saludamos a
las personas que nos escuchan en nuestro
podcast los invito para que escuchen
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
que ya están disponibles en app el
podcast en spotify en dice
pues muy bien damos entonces inicio a
este análisis que vamos a hacer sobre
este tema le doy la bienvenida entonces
al doctor mutuo en la ciudad de kobeny
japón para hablar sobre este tema
bienvenido doctor mutuo y mi primera
pregunta el punto de partida para esta
discusión desde su punto de vista cuál
es el legado que deja sin suave para la
política japonesa y también la
relevancia que tuvo a nivel
internacional y luego ya iremos
profundizando en diferentes temas
encantado
si ese en primer lugar hay que acentuar
que ex primer ministro shinzo abe
restaura el gobierno más largo en la
historia de japón
generalmente en la política japonesa la
duración media del gabinete es muy corta
y por eso el gobierno no puede hacerse
hacer las políticas desde punto de vista
a medio y largo plazo además en la
escena diplomacia el primer ministro
japonés no ha prestado tanta atención
comparando el papel internacional de
japón
ha sido los problemas de patadas en del
político japonés
en este sentido puede evaluarse el que
el gobierno ve hacia las políticas
continuadas
específicamente en la política económica
y diplomática diplomática independiente
de sus resultados
al mismo tiempo dentro del jabón es
conocido el lado negativo del gobierno
de ave en primer lugar en el su manera
política autoritario con la parte
mayoritaria
absoluta en el congreso y debilitado de
la oposición política los asuntos de que
a veces en auckland enfrentaban sobre
todo el de seguridad estaba muy
convertido por eso su manera autoritaria
era muy destacada
a ser utilizado con frecuencia la manera
que divide el partidario y enemigos como
los líderes populistas
doctor voy a darle la palabra a
florentino rodar nuestro invitado en la
ciudad de honolulu también para conocer
su punto de vista a punto de partida
señor rodado sobre el legado de shinzo
abe y el impacto que tiene su muerte
para la vida política de japón y también
a nivel internacional ya hemos visto las
repercusiones y los mensajes de pésame
que han expresado muchos líderes a nivel
internacional
bueno ciudad e incluso el en india han
declarado un día de luto
en la ópera de cine y también han hecho
cosas a ver a un personaje internacional
lo ha dicho muy bien
el profesor mutuo que efectivamente es
el político japonés que ha sido más
conocido no solamente porque ha estado
durante el que más tiempo ha estado
sabes bien en ese sentido sí que es
importante pero creo que también tenemos
que aprender otra cosa nuestra que nos
sirve para nosotros es decir japonés un
poco la sociedad más adelantada en
muchas cosas y ahí tenemos que aprender
por ejemplo una de ellas es el declive
de la población no esa población cada
vez más envejecida
que los japoneses son los primeros en
tenerlo porque como no han admitido
emigrantes buscaba de alguna forma pues
sin apenas inmigrantes no sé no se
renueva la población vale pues sí que es
verdad que a ve a por primera vez ha
planteado en el para el futuro de japón
una serie de cosas que eran muy
necesarias por primera vez un político
se ha podido saber en japón lo que iba a
ocurrir el año siguiente y al otro más o
menos con una cierta estabilidad que no
había habido entonces pues fíjate el
problema que está enfrentando japón es
el de la el de la natalidad si no me
equivoco el último año han sido 640 mil
japoneses menos de población me parece
son 120 millones ahora quédate es una
cantidad importante no claro eso que
significa que haya muchos muchos menos
japoneses y una población cada vez más
envejecida que son 75 años bueno pues
por ejemplo varias cosas una a las
mujeres tienen que acceder al trabajo y
no solamente para cuestiones para
trabajos secundarios sino también como
altos cargos por otro lado los jubilados
también tienen que permitirles trabajar
porque no hay ahí es necesario y luego
por otro lado el más doloroso para ellos
ha sido el tener que admitir a
emigrantes y eso bueno en eso había
hecho un poco lo que todos los políticos
suelen hacer no es decir que no vamos a
admitir emigrantes pero lobos filosas y
eso es un poco del legado que podemos
decir de algo que hubo varias reformas a
nivel político que hay que destacar
durante la gestión de el primer ministro
ave en algo importante y es una pregunta
que está ahora circulando en medios
internacionales es porque a raíz de el
anuncio de la renuncia de abel 28 de
agosto en el 2020 se produjo un pulso
interno entre las facciones de su
partido el lp ahora que él ha fallecido
pese a que ya no era una figura pública
pero seguía trabajando para su partido
precisamente falleció durante un acto de
campaña en donde recibió estos dos
disparos ay doctor mutuo nuevamente
disputas al interior del partido por
tratar de llenar ese vacío que deja ave
al interior del partido del lp
y en la elección del este este domingo
de de cámara alta
japonesa es en los partidos en el
gobierno en rpp estén ganaron
sí pero
este resultado estaba previsto antes del
accidente entonces más bien hay que
prestar atención al interior del pp de
la pierna del personal más urgente del
grupo conservador derechista es decir
sin suave
afectar la la dinámica interior de la
partida rumbo política
1 es lo importante
especialmente quizá el movimiento hacia
la reforma con constitución
es un tema
más soñado
si la reforma a la constitución ya lo
vamos a comentar más adelante lo tengo
dentro de mis temas doctor el señor
rodado en la ciudad de honolulu en hawai
su perspectiva de lo que puede
representar este vacío o en la ausencia
de la figura de ave al interior del lp
que lo llevó pues prácticamente a un
liderazgo en japón prácticamente no
tenían una oposición
muy bien concertada y le permitió
gobernar con tranquilidad que significa
entonces la ausencia de él para la
política japonesa
bueno él ya estaba retirado sí que se
estaba hablando había habido rumores de
que quizás podría volver a la política
japonesa
pero de alguna forma sí que es verdad el
dentro de ese gobierno de coalición que
puede ser el partido liberal democrático
es decir con muchas facciones en el aire
al que representaba la facción más
derechista y en ese sentido al
desaparecer el sí que es verdad que esa
fracción va a necesitar por decirlo
alguna forma un nuevo líder su facción
política por ejemplo bueno en japón en
las dentro del parlamento dentro del
partido liberal democrático hay
diferentes facciones y es verdad que se
va a necesitar hacer un nuevo líder un
nuevo líder y también es verdad que
había varios partidos pequeños
gijón calle etcétera que de alguna forma
están en esta ocasión fíjate lo más
curioso en ese sentido clarence un poco
enlazando con lo que dice conocer mucho
y con lo que está estaba hablando su
ironía de que precisamente su muerte
pues ha llevado a esta victoria tan
grande del partido liberal-democrático
que podría permitir esos dos tercios del
parlamento es decir en la cámara alta y
la baja que pudieran permitir esa
cambio de la constitución
y un cambio importante hay que decir que
cuando él renunció
a su cargo pues no nombró a ningún
sucesor claramente hubo hay un momento
de disputas internas como lo decía
finalmente yo sí he de zug a quienes hoy
en día el primer ministro de japón llegó
a este cargo era un político veterano en
japón durante mucho tiempo fue
integrante precisamente del gabinete de
ministros de ave y era alguien más o
menos cercano pero él no nombró a nadie
entonces por eso se habla de estas
disputas al interior del partido pasemos
a hablar un poco de esa postura que ya
mencionaba el doctor mucho sobre esa
línea más dura que tenía esa línea
nacionalista que le deja es precisamente
esa línea nacionalista a la política
japonesa
japonesa doctor mutó porque eso sin
embargo generó ciertas tensiones por
ejemplo con korea que es un país muy
cercano a japón también con china y con
rusia que es un país con el que mantiene
una atención por las islas kuriles ese
ese sentimiento nacionalista de que le
sirvió a japón en la construcción
política
a ver si
tenía
la ideología
muy
derechista y conservador pero al mismo
tiempo
avn no producían conflictos graves con
países vecinos que tiene el problema
histórica delicada por ejemplo en cólera
de su oficina pero aunque sí pero sobre
todo es en
construir la relación recíproca
estratégica con china mostrar la doble
problemática de la cia de haber este
punto en punto tienen evaluable
si un punto evaluable como como es esa
relación que él deja con china o que le
dejó al actual ministro al primer
ministro su ga como la relación entre
tokio y beijing al día de hoy
si puedes creer el primer ministro no
actuaran kishida también sean suya
jesús es el sucesor de la línea
diplomática
porque es la china es
el país más importante del vecino del
destino de japón especialmente es el
punto de vista económico pero si hay una
posibilidad de la esclava con conflicto
especialmente tras la conflictos
territoriales
señor rodado su perspectiva sobre este
tema sobre la relación que deja con los
países vecinos y esa línea nacionalista
en esa construcción política de japonesa
usted ya lo mencionaba unos temas que
eran muy prácticamente vetados para la
sociedad japonesa que les tocó abrirse y
empezar a aceptar algunos cambios para
esta sociedad que se envejece
fíjate es que claro estamos hablando de
nacionalismo japonés con el cual hay una
como has dicho muy bien hay unos hay una
confrontación muy clara con china con
corea dependiendo de en korea de si
gobiernan los de derechas o los de
izquierdas también es verdad que hay
mucho cambio en ese sentido y con rusia
se puede decir es el gran fracaso de la
diplomacia japonesa es decir no haber
firmado todavía la paz después de la
segunda guerra pero claro estás hablando
de nacionalismo muy bien pero por otro
lado ese nacionalismo no es frente a
eeuu es decir es hacer lo que hago con
eeuu y cuánto trump qué trampa había
criticado en las elecciones a japón el
primero que fue a visitarle una vez que
ganó las elecciones fue a ver pues ese
nacionalismo es un tanto complicado y lo
que ha hecho ave en ese sentido yo estoy
acuerdo con luto es decir sí que es
verdad que ha hecho una relación pero de
alguna forma así que se puede decir que
a vez un pragmático frente a la anterior
consumí que les provocó a los chinos
innecesariamente en ese sentido efe muy
derechista es decir no reconocía varios
asuntos de la guerra de la guerra
mundial que eran básicos pero sí que es
verdad que fue pragmático y trató de
evitar por ejemplo una cosa que podemos
decir que es una tontería la visita el
15 de agosto al templo yasukuni honrando
a los japoneses muertos durante la
guerra eso es una cosa que a los chinos
les presentaba muy mal que koizumi hizo
y por ejemplo evitó de hacerlo en ese
sentido este nacionalismo tiene que
adaptarse a que ya no es tan poderoso es
decir la economía china le ha superado
por mucho a la economía de japón y en
ese sentido era muy derechista pero
también de alguna forma hay que
agradecerle que tenía un cierto
pragmatismo
señor rodado porque esta relevancia a
nivel internacional entendiendo estas
diferencias del nacionalismo japonés que
se aplicaban para algunos escenarios
internacionales y para otros no y me
gustaría preguntarle por el caso de
américa latina qué relación pudo haberse
estrechado con con américa latina' y
japón y cómo es que él llega a ser una
figura tan importante en la escena
internacional
estando al mando de japón durante tantos
años
fíjate con américa latina'
se podría decir bueno que hay japón es
un país dentro de su política exterior
que piensa mucho a largo plazo y piensa
mucho en los lazos culturales piensa
mucho en esa imagen que está dando y en
ese sentido hay que agradecerle porque
japón y américa latina' efectivamente no
es tan importante como debería de ser
pero japón siempre ha reconocido digamos
el hispanismo a los países de américa
latina más allá por supuesto de esas
materias primas entonces en ese sentido
la política japonesa lo tiene muy claro
hay que trabajar a largo plazo hay
trabajar en una imagen japón tiene una
imagen excelente en américa latina' por
supuesto también en españa no y en ese
sentido sí que es verdad es una cosa que
hay que reconocer a los japoneses su
visión a largo plazo en la política
exterior en ese sentido con américa
latina' le tienen mucho cuidado tienen
mucha preocupación de esa enseñanza del
español y se nota la verdad en su
política exterior
doctor mucho su opinión sobre este tema
esta dualidad que se ve de ese
nacionalismo y de esa forma de llevar
las relaciones internacionales se
muestra muy rígido muy
sacando pecho por su nacionalismo
japonés en las relaciones con los países
de la cuenca del pacífico pero con otros
países por ejemplo con europa bueno la
unión europea con estados unidos canadá
américa latina se muestra un país un
poco más dócil más enfocado en temas
económicos
si
el punto de vista de la económica
[Música]
para los japón los países más más
importantes en que por supuesto a eeuu y
china o algún país es en el sudeste de
asia hacía entonces en
los políticos japoneses
no entiendo la importancia de por
ejemplo
áfrica o américa latina como profesor
rodeado de dicho entonces en
su nación el
nacionalismo
disfrutáis pero así es entonces en la
diplomacia de abc en el viernes
tienen los aspectos
más nacionalistas y también en otros es
muy pragmático desde entonces pero es
lean sobre el extenso en su política
económica que se llama a denominaciones
eso no es importante en nuestro
importante de las
américas 1 si aplicas si allí por
ejemplo en áfrica y juega un papel mucho
más importante china en este momento
mucho más allá que japón el señor rodado
pasó a preguntarle ahora por el tema de
la defensa y el tema militar un tema que
genera mucha controversia en japón a
raíz de los antecedentes que tiene este
país en la en su participación en las
guerras mundiales y bueno y lo que
desencadenó para japón y lo que
representó la segunda guerra mundial
para este país había un punto ahí
importante que tiene que ver con la
constitución era ese deseo de enmendar
la constitución pacifista que tiene
japón
que es una
constitución impulsada por eeuu también
apoyada por eeuu fue colaborador allí en
la construcción de esta carta magna pero
él buscaba darle una una un cambio cuál
era el cambio que buscaba el ex primer
ministro ave en temas militares darle
cierto reconocimiento al ejército
me lo pregunto si bien aquí lo era había
una frase muy famosa dice japón lo que
queremos es que sea un país normal no
sólo decía otro de los de los
derechistas esto es no es decir que
japón tenga un ejército no decir acabar
con esa constitución efectivamente que
como ha dicho muy muy bien fue impulsada
por eeuu y que los propios eeuu
quisieron cambiarla al final cuando ya
empezó la guerra ya no hay es un dilema
un dilema muy importante de japón porque
ahí las dos almas japonesas esos del
japón como país normal y esos muchos
japoneses también que se avergüenzan de
lo que ocurrió y que están muy contentos
digamos con esa constitución que era
efectivamente impulsada por eeuu al
comienzo del de la ocupación y no
después porque fue asimilada por los
propios japoneses ahí es un dilema muy
grande dentro de la sociedad y se ve
claramente estaba un lado lo que pasa es
que ahí de alguna forma esa gente que lo
quiere revocar esta idea están muy
aislados y precisamente el fracaso de
ave en ese sentido de reformarlas la
constitución
es que aunque podían tener un apoyo de
esos dos tercios el partido minoritario
que estaba gobernando con el partido
budista digamos esos de alguna forma lo
rechazaron porque hay otra cosa muy
crucial en la política japonesas es que
tratan de evitar que sea divisiva no es
decir tratan de evitar de que haya temas
en los cuales gane uno o varios entonces
el reformar la constitución o permitir
que la constitución de japón fuera una
constitución
belicista digamos o que pudiera tener
ejército más que mayoría no mayoría
habría provocado a toda la sociedad y
eso de alguna forma es lo que él
quisieron evitar los otros partidos no y
efectivamente nuestra cambia bueno pues
vamos a preguntarle al doctor mutó por
este tema esta opinión diversidad de
opiniones que hay en la sociedad
japonesa en torno al tema del ejército
del cambio de la constitución usted como
ciudadano japonés como que está allí en
el día a día pocas veces podemos
preguntarle a una persona de primera
mano sobre este tipo de situaciones cuál
es el sentir de la sociedad japonesa en
torno a este tema
y de hecho la opinión que debería a
reformarla en los artículos de la
constitución
incluyendo el artículo nuevo esa es la
símbolo del pacifismo de jabón y
adaptándose a las tics importancia de
internacional nestlé ya no es la opinión
de minoría a ver el mismo en el mismo
voy a poner la vila en la reforma
constitucional de su actividad política
pero sobre todo se ha realizado
hay dos razones una la reforma
constitucional constitucional aún este
asunto muy delicado y otro es el partido
de oposición especialmente especialmente
del exterior izquierda oponían
de forma
pero
si le pregunto doctor mutuo ese sentido
también de la sociedad japonesa por el
tema del ejército la necesidad de un
reconocimiento y dejar esa constitución
pacifista también obedece a ese
sentimiento que puede sentirse en
occidente de china volviendo así una
potencia militar estando tan cerca de el
archipiélago japonés
ustedes lo ven como una amenaza a nivel
militar
así y especialmente en
y después de la
muerte del ave quizá ser movimiento
hacia la reforma constitucional hacia el
ala de un golpe pero si no es en dos
porque es el deseo de haber sino porque
la círculo de circunstancias de
estabilidad de japón ha cambiado
automáticamente en por ejemplo es la la
posibilidad de la ex expansión de china
es la de sueño también es lo más
importante es la guerra de ocurra ya que
está afectando la opinión sobre la
reforma constitucional y de momento ya
la por tanto el porcentaje de la quien
apoyará la reforma ha subido muy muy
harta si hay un cambio hay en el parecer
de la sociedad japonesa señor rodado en
lo que representa
este incremento en gasto militar en
china y también lo que representa rusia
en este momento estando involucrada en
la guerra con ucrania cambia entonces
esta perspectiva de una reforma en la
constitución dentro de la sociedad
japonesa cuál puede ser su análisis
que algo habrá no habrá una nueva
constitución en el sentido de pop ya he
dicho que es muy divisivo pero bueno
hace unos días hemos visto que por
primera vez el primer ministro japonés
está en una reunión de la otan de la
nato no igual que el coreano esto
entonces sí que efectivamente eso se
hará muy poca importancia se ha dado se
ha hablado sobre todo de la entrada
finlandia y suecia en la otan pero lo
cierto es que por primera vez en japón
un primer ministro japonés o coreano han
participado en la otan y desde luego
está muy claro en la opinión clara de la
otan de él de tratar a china como
enemigo system ya que algún tipo de
cambio desde luego sí que va haber algún
tipo de claro allí estamos esperando la
organización digamos de seguridad en el
atlántico norte está muy clara con ese
eeuu que eeuu y europa en el caso ya sea
la seguridad está más complicada porque
han sido básicamente acuerdos
bilaterales de eeuu uno con japón otro
con corea luego con filipinas es decir
básicamente a dos bilaterales excepto
china china de alguna forma la aceptaba
pero sí que efectivamente tiene que
haber un nuevo esquema de seguridad en
el pacífico desde hace muchos años eso
lo tenemos que se me permite es que
comenté una cosa que ha hecho muy bien
para mí el profesor mucho pero quiero
añadir adelante fíjate para mí hay una
cosa causó historiador hay que pensar a
largo plazo no fíjate para mí hace unos
años se les preguntaron a los japoneses
cuál era el país más más más cercano a
ellos no y fíjate dentro de esos
japoneses el 60 por ciento me parece
respondió taiwán es decir un país que no
sé hasta qué punto es no está en las
naciones unidas había me parece que
solamente un 11 por ciento de japoneses
que el país que sentía el más cercano
era corea corea del sur otro 5% corea
del norte y con china también un
porcentaje muy pequeño entonces el
problema de japón es que es japón y
nadie más es un japonés un país
relativamente aislado no pues sí que es
verdad que japón tiene que dar
and tender puentes hacia el resto del
continente con la gente que es y ganar
más culturalmente a fin es un problema
de japón a largo plazo que implica mucho
más por decirle alguna forma que la
cuestión de la seguridad
y ese tema de estar aislado se ve
reflejado en el tema migratorio que son
pocas las personas que se van a vivir
allí a este país el señor rodado le
pregunto por una de las conclusiones que
hubo ese encuentro de la otan en la
ciudad de madrid en españa una de las
conclusiones fue que aparte de
consolidarse en el atlántico norte había
que darle un vistazo al pacífico
justamente lo que usted estaba
mencionando que había que empezar a
hacer presencia allí esa presencia usted
la puede analizar como que vaya también
enfocada o enrutada a que japón dé un
cambio en esa política militar que
trataba de implementar el ex-ministro
ave en su cambio a la constitución esto
va por el mismo camino podemos ver a un
japón metido en una alianza militar a
gran escala a nivel internacional sí sí
sí sí efectivamente por ahí va ya digo
más que constitución nueva constitución
o algo así algún tipo de integración
yo lo veo así más bien no como una cosa
exclusiva de japón sino de alguna forma
de todo el continente ya digo se tienen
que acabar esos acuerdos bilaterales
entre eeuu con otros países y hacer una
organización global y eso es lo que de
alguna forma viendo lo que ocurrió con
la otan etcétera no en madrid' que se
echaba en falta que hubiera algo
parecido o si la otan se expande lo que
sea algo parecido para el océano
pacífico en el cual obviamente tendría
que entrar colombia américa latina'
etcétera no pero sí que es verdad que se
echa en falta un otro tipo de o de
organización supranacional que solventar
estos problemas pues luego también sabe
muy claramente los pruebas tanto de
japón con corea del norte como con corea
del sur por supuesto con china se nunca
mencionado con con rusia no ahí yo lo
veo un problema más que del japón como
tal un problema general regional a
general de la organización de de defensa
para el pacífico y en el cual incluyó
también por supuesto américa latina
en el doctor mutó le pregunto ahora por
el tema de la seguridad interna la
visión que tenemos desde américa latina
y tal vez desde otras partes del mundo
es que japón es un país extremadamente
seguro pocas cosas graves suceden allí
más allá de hechos políticos aislados o
de cosas aisladas en la sociedad el
asesinato del ex primer ministro es un
antes y un después en la historia de la
seguridad japonesa cuál es el sentir de
los japoneses en torno a ese tema y qué
es lo que ha generado
este tipo de hechos asesinar al ex
primer ministro en la calle es sin duda
alguna un hecho de violencia de gran
escala
por qué
la verdad es la primera
un momentito
bueno le trasladó la pregunta entonces
al señor rodado mientras el doctor mucho
organiza sus notas porque el tiempo
corre en televisión y se va volando el
señor rodado su opinión sobre este tema
de la seguridad estos un antes y un
después en ese concepto en seguridad que
teníamos por lo menos de este país bueno
ya que estás hablando de la importancia
de la prensa es normal que se hable
ahora de esto de estas cuestiones de la
seguridad pero no creo que a largo plazo
vaya a tener un impacto no olvidemos que
el rifle se lo había hecho este este
mismo hombre además utilizando celofán
etcétera como medidas a largo plazo no
no podemos pensar que vaya a ser
importante en ese sentido esa
y despreocupación de japón en la
cuestión de la seguridad hay que
agradecerlo otra cosa cuidado y no
olvidemos es el tema de la política y
los atentados a los políticos que ha
habido en japón a lo largo de la
historia el propio abuelo de
de ave también fue casi asesinado
sobrevivió de milagro a un puñal a a una
serie de puñaladas que le dieron el en
esos mismos tiempos también por ejemplo
asesinaron al jefe del partido
socialista además delante de las cámaras
eso fue incluso el premio nobel que el
seguro escribió sobre ello asesinaron
delante de las cámaras al dirigente
socialista es decir la conexión de la
extrema derecha atentando contra
políticos japoneses es una cosa es
recurrente recientemente también fue el
alcalde de hiroshima o sea eso no
olvidemos la presencia de la extrema
derecha como atentados políticos y el
tema de la seguridad en japón yo creo
que va a seguir tan tan relajado porque
no hay violencia las asociaciones ahí no
hay argumentos
claro eso ayuda mucho ahora sí doctor
mucho su opinión adelante ya muchas
gracias
y en primer lugar es en este aspecto
experto
uy horrible y bombazo es la primera
asesinato del político tan influyente
como ex ministro ex primer ministro al
menos después tras la segunda guerra
mundial pero si hubieron algunos
asesinatos en un antes de la segunda
guerra mundial como el profesor
repitiendo ahora va a dicho pero en es
importante según las noticias japonesas
el detenido no tenía ningún tendencia
ideológica o política entonces aún no
puede afirmarse que este accidente es
asesinato con objetivo político o el
terrorismo político de momento las
noticias japonesas expresan este este
existente como el desafío a la
democracia o el bloqueo de la palabra
con violencia pero hay que analizar con
un karma
y es una investigación que está en curso
ya veremos qué dice esta investigación
me quedan un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero entonces
hacer las conclusiones comienzo con el
señor rodado en la ciudad de honolulu en
hawai lo que trae entonces de aquí en
adelante no hay bola de cristal siempre
lo digo para saber cuál va a ser el
futuro pero sin duda alguna esto va a
sentar un precedente en la historia
política y en los meses venideros para
japón que sigue entonces para japón
ahora sí en este líder importante en la
escena política del país
continuar la internacionalización lo
tengo muy claro japón se va igual que en
el período previo la era heisei fue
básicamente el japon cultural más allá
de las inversiones etcétera ahora están
continuar la la
internacionalización con una política
más moderada ahora la preocupación y
sobre todo eso muy claro en el caso x
ida que está muy relacionado con el
ministerio de finanzas se largamente
ahora es la aprobación financiera el
dinero la economía la economía que es
una preocupación para todos los países
en este momento doctor mucho su
conclusión que sigue para su país para
los próximos meses en términos políticos
si es la
[Música]
si en inglés
el primer ministro actualidad es en
suceder algún
algunos asuntos de ave por ejemplo es la
isla
pero al mismo tiempo es la
ideología más liberará entonces y
entonces en japón es hacerlo en quien
quizás cambiar un poquito la
política interna o económicamente pero
sí sí pero en la diplomacia nada
cambiará en tanto las ticamente es decir
la diplomacia paseando con áreas eeuu
asia
bueno pues a florentino rodado en la
ciudad de honolulu en hawai le agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros al
doctor somoto y le agradezco por haber
estado también en el programa por haber
hecho su esfuerzo por hablar español y
darnos a entender y explicarnos en sus
propias palabras estos temas de la
política japonesa que es tan ajena para
américa latina le agradezco mucho y
ustedes gracias por la sintonía pueden
seguir dejando todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
ya las conocen sigan con la programación
de france 24
[Música]